senator elizabeth warren has a stern
warning for democrats in a lengthy op-ed
she writes this here's a quote to put it
bluntly if we fail to use the months
remaining before the elections to
deliver on more of our agenda democrats
are headed towards big losses in the
midterms this as the washington post
ranks possible 20 24 front runners
putting vp harris in third behind mayor
pete the paper saying we're dropping
harris down a slot this time she's done
little to change the perceptions that
harmed her in 2020 including on her
ability to drive a message fox news
contributor former democrat himself leo
terrell joins us now leo can you believe
it you know
when jimmy carter was president ted
kennedy ran against him it really hurt
the democratic party
they don't care about hurting the
democrat this would be a democratic
incumbent and they don't care about
running possible prospects out there why
i'll tell you why because you have the
weakest president you mentioned jimmy
carter
joe bide is worse than jimmy carter and
i'll tell you right now brian when you
talk about the carter administration at
least they try to be for the working
class the democratic party today
is not the party of the working class
it's the party of the elite they have
turned their backs on the democratic
working-class people think about it
brian working-class people want safe
streets they want good schools they want
the border secure
and they want inflation down democrats
are not even thinking about that they're
talking about continuation of the bite
administration policies which you cannot
defend it's indefensible all right so
one of the quotes from elizabeth
warren's column was this another one
while republican politicians peddle lies
fear and division we should use every
single one of the next 200 days uh or so
before the election to deliver
meaningful improvement for working
people
is that why they're going to bat for
trans rights and
uh uh talking about hormone blockers
you know what i i'll tell you right now
brian i was a democrat i'm a school
teacher and that's not what working
class americans want at all
elizabeth warren is in a bubble because
what she's asking the big administration
to do is double down on the policies
that are currently failing they're
failing this country and what they're in
denial of is what was going on what was
working before they took office was
working but of course that would have to
be giving uh kudos to trump and they're
not going to do that i want to show the
people at home this list who don't get
the washington post to live it to their
doorstep
president biden's number one so that's
good news for him he is the president
pete budder judge number two for being
doing such a great job of the supply
chain uh vice president harris doing a
fantastic job at the border elizabeth
warren's been so quiet klobuchar's
number five
governor roy cooper sherrod brown who
decided not to run last time cory booker
uh number eight gavin newsom horrific
job almost recalled out in california
and then the queen's his own aoc
out of that group who are you looking at
right now if you're a democrat i notice
there's no moderates there you don't see
cuellar you don't see mansion
please let me tell you you got the
weakest incumbent president ever i want
to be very clear save this tape
kamala harris elected political career
is over she'll never win again pete
budajed the man who talks a lot but says
nothing this is a very very weak
democratic bench i would pick number 11
on there and sisters only 10 number 11
is the best candidate on that list brian
number 11 is the best someone's not
there hey tulsi gabriel i thought was
the best debater she was the first one
to expose kamal harris on the stage but
uh doesn't really have much momentum
inside the party uh
great to see you they don't like
moderates they don't like moderates they
the democratic party like i said the
working class the democratic party is
not the party of the moderates uh
kristen cinema joe manchin tulsi gabbard
their
i'm telling you right now if they ran
mansion if they i don't know much about
uh cinema in detail but if they did they
get some republican votes but we'll see
absolutely leo thanks so much hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now